this episode is brought to you by
Peloton and their brand new Peloton row
Peloton row brings personalized form
features and guidance to rowing to help
you learn and master your stroke this
was always a weak point for me meaning
before I used volaton row and I got to
test a unit a few weeks ago here in
Austin which blew me away my form was
just a question mark and I also tended
to flame out after five or ten minutes
on a rower I just really didn't know
what I was doing and with the Peloton
row that all changed the instructors
first and foremost highly trained
Fitness Pros many different types who
motivate you through every rowing
workout I really enjoyed my training
sessions with Alex karwaski specifically
he's a current high-level International
competitor in rowing so you know his
technique has been refined Peloton
offers a huge variety of workouts like
high intensity interval training hit
rows endurance rows and more with the
feedback that I was able to get so you
effectively see a profile of yourself
and based on sensors at different points
in the machine you will see feedback I
was able to then do a much more
sustained workout to actually tax
different metabolic systems and I felt
spectacular afterwards form features
like form assist indicate how to improve
your stroke in class in real time and
you also get a detailed post-class
breakdown so you can hit the rail harder
but more technically next time in my
opinion you can turn off the pharmacist
after about three minutes or so you'll
probably get most of what you're going
to get in each of those sessions and
you'd want to become too overly
concerned with that so that it detracts
from your experience with all these
features you can personalize your target
metrics you become the expert at the
level and Pace that feels good for you
you get all the cardio and strength in
one shot while protecting your joints
and ligaments in a high intensity but
low impact method of exercise and this
blew my mind also my ankles sometimes
hurt when I've tried rowing in the past
and by getting the proper instruction
and I felt no pain in my feet or my
ankles whatsoever and the Pelton row
fits seamlessly into your life so
whether you have a 10 minute segment of
time a little break between calls or if
you want to do something longer in a low
impact row on a recovery day all those
options are available and the Peloton
row also can be stored vertically so
when you're not using it it's out of
sight out of mind it's also effectively
near silent when you're using it there's
a class for every schedule you can work
out hard for the time that you have and
trust that you're getting the most out
of each workout right now it is the
perfect time to get rowing with haloton
row I can promise that you've never rode
like this before the Forum feedback the
pharmacist
I was really really impressed Peloton
row offers a variety of classes for all
levels Plus game changing features that
help you get rowing or Advance the
rowing you already do so explore Peloton
row at one Peloton that's o-n-e one
peloton.com row one more time that's one
peloton.com row
this episode is brought to you by you
need a budget what is you need a budget
you need a budget is a cult favorite
budgeting app for a reason the app and
its simple four rule method will change
the way you think about your money and
help you gain total control so you can
plan for the things you need and get the
things you want without guilt or stress
to give you an idea on the cult favorite
side to date they know of at least seven
customers who have customized their
license plates to Mark the occasion of
purchasing a new car in cash and these
fans do this by including YNAB you need
a budget on their license plates so
people love this app you need a budget
has helped millions of people transform
their finances save their marriages and
live life on their own terms I even
asked Pete Adney who's been on the
podcast best known as Mr Money Mustache
super popular episode what he thought
and he's a big fan of the founder and
what they're doing you need a budgets
simple four rule method will actually
teach you how to manage your money you
will learn a new way of thinking new
habits and new behaviors that will help
you get out of debt break the paycheck
to paycheck cycle and build wealth
faster the you need a budget team is
committed to your success they offer
free live classes every day of the week
video courses boot camps challenges and
active fan groups in every corner of the
internet if you want to learn they can
teach you on average new budgeters save
more than 600 by month two and six
thousand dollars in their first year so
try the app free for 34 days no credit
card required at you need a budget.com
Tim spelled as you would expect in
proper English try you need a budget
free for 34 days no credit card required
at you need a budget.com slash Tim and
just to explain 34 days that's because
most people reconcile at the end of the
month or 38 periods of having a couple
of days of cushion helps folks out so 34
days with no credit card required at you
need a budget.com slash Tim optimal
minimals at this altitude I can run flat
out for a half mile before my hands
starts shaking can I ask you a personal
questions
[Music]
living tissue over metal endoskeletons
ladies and gentlemen this is Tim Ferriss
welcome to another episode of the Tim
Ferriss show my guest today needs no
introduction but I will provide one
regardless Rick Rubin you can find him
on Twitter at Rick Rubin is a nine-time
grammy-winning producer one of Time
magazine's 100 most influential people
in the world and the most successful
producer in any genre according to
Rolling Stone he has collaborated with
artists ranging from Tom Petty to Adele
Johnny Cash to the Red Hot Chili Peppers
Beastie Boys to Slayer Kanye West of The
Strokes and System of a Down to Jay-Z
that is just the tip of the iceberg
believe it or not you can find my 2015
interview
seven plus years ago was red
unbelievable isn't that crazy Tim dot
blog slash Rick Rubin his new book is
the creative act subtitle a way of being
we're gonna dig into that Rick seven
plus years ago I can't believe it was
that the first year of the podcast how
many years the podcast been that would
have been the second year of the podcast
and we recorded it in your sauna which
was a condition of yours yes we did a
lot of heat we did a lot of cold
though the creative act why make this
book and I've had some close-up seats to
watch the seeds germinating for quite a
while now I feel like we may have talked
about this even back in the sauna I
don't know if we talked about it on the
podcast but we did the same day yeah
talking about this is a book I want to
write and I remember you amongst others
you were not the only one you were one
of everyone else who said that sounds
like a bad idea the general consensus
was
that sounds like a lot of work and it's
not the book that anybody necessarily
wants from you
why don't you just do the one that's
easy hold on hold on let me let me
defend myself here for one second I
definitely said the first part I think
what I probably said was Rick you have a
lot going on if you put this book out in
the world you're gonna have to live with
it forever so are you sure you are
willing to put or can find the time in
the space to create this book I wouldn't
have said I don't think this is the book
people want to read I would have just
said man you have a lot of optionality
in your life are you sure this is the
path that you want to take I could see
saying that but here we are well I'll
say this is the book that was
interesting to me to write and there
were definitely simpler books to write
but I wasn't interested so and that was
a general consensus with everyone I
talked to including Publishers at that
time yeah who just said well you know
why don't you do a biography why don't
you do the stories of your life it's
like if that was the book I wouldn't do
the book right totally this is the only
book that was interesting to me
to work on what the purpose of it is is
over the course of a year
I might get to work with a handful of
artists probably the most albums I've
ever produced in a year would be eight
which is a lot for a record producer
but in the world of artists it's a tiny
fraction so even though I've been doing
it for a long time even though I get to
work with a lot for someone who does my
job I'm still talking to a very few
people and it seems like what goes on in
the studio is helpful for the artists
and the idea that maybe there's some way
that this information can be shared and
it's difficult because I don't know what
it is you know that was maybe part of
when I describe remember you I remember
you know I don't know
it's like I don't know what's in the
book I don't even know where to start
Publishers love that pitch by the way
no I remember you saying that though and
I was like okay that's interesting I
mean you have the ability
at this point in your life and at that
point in your life to actually play with
that emergence though and I guess you've
done that a lot in your life not limited
just to This Book Project that's the way
I like to work it's like I go in with
with kind of a blind belief that
something good will happen and until
it's proven impossible I will continue
banging my head against the wall
so I want to talk about banging the head
against the wall I want to talk about
creative process how you work with
artists how you work with yourself also
in the case of this book I must say
something before I forget to mention it
which is I was reading the book I didn't
read all of it because I didn't want to
spoil it for myself but I was reading
the book and I thought you know this
reminds me of something something that I
have and something now that I think
about it that Rick Rubin has mentioned
before this is not the exact book you've
mentioned but the touted absolutely that
bears a resemblance just in terms of the
flow and the bite-sized nature and the
lyrical prose if I can put it that way
the way that you've encapsulated your
thinking in the writing am I totally off
base or is this is is that an echo that
was always one of The Wishes
was to have a dow-like experience the
material in the book isn't very much
like the Dow and there's a lot more
content in this book than is in the Dow
yeah the Tao is 81 short pieces this is
400 and some odd pages that was one of
the threads another one was the artist
way even though I don't think the books
like the artist's way but what's special
about the artist's way is that it's not
Julie Cameron's story in any way it's a
book with things that might be helpful
and I wanted it to be like that I didn't
want it to be about any of my
experiences any of my projects any of
the people I've worked with I wanted it
to be about the mindset
that allows the creation to happen and
because it comes to me intuitively and I
don't know how it works
it took since seven years ago to get to
this point of understanding it and even
now
I don't know that I could clearly
explain it to you because the nature of
the stuff
that we're talking about is fleeting
it's like if you read the Dao every year
you'll get something completely
different out of it it's like that it's
not vague it's pretty specific but it is
open to interpretation in the best way
where it's inviting you the reader
to see your picture I'm not telling you
what to think
I'm setting up a world that you can
participate in yourself
what's strictly that you're in a of
course metaphorical sense
explaining how one can calibrate their
instrumentation you're not telling them
what to read or what to sense but you're
saying this is how you might increase
the spectrum of frequencies or inputs
that you are able to register and then
what you choose to do with that is up to
you but let's talk about sensitivity
let's talk about awareness and I was
struck by a number of examples so there
were examples in the book of opening
other books and flipping to say a random
page and finding a line and using that
line as a catalyst of some type and if
you don't mind me hopping around a
little bit I wanted to go back to our
first conversation
to discuss how the very small can lead
to the very big so this is an anecdote
that you shared after I asked you how
you helped musicians break through
barriers the same way that Laird
Hamilton helped you break through
certain physical and psychological
barriers often interrelated and what you
mentioned then was that in some cases
you give artists homework very small
doable tasks and you told the story of
working with a musician who had a very
good career at one point was trying to
get back into songwriting and he had all
these unfinished songs and I think the
homework assignment was come back
tomorrow with one word that you like and
then you were able to string those
together
and help him to build a certain momentum
that then led to of course larger
finished pieces did you use that
yourself with this book at all and or is
there another example you could give of
breaking something down into very small
pieces that then produce their own
momentum in the case of the book the way
that I was able to
get to the information in it was through
doing hundreds of hours of interviews
either about specific projects or on the
day of a studio session I would come
home from the session and I would make
notes on okay this happened today I
would take whatever happened in the
specific of whatever happened in the
studio that day where something good
happened where no one knew what to do
and the next thing you know we're all
talking about it and then something
happens and we like solve the problem
all together everyone wherever the idea
came from it was solved
and then I would look at that and see is
there a principle at work in that
solution bigger than this problem where
it's applicable to other problems it and
you could imagine in any work that
you've done
if you solve one kind of a problem there
could come up something similar or
something that rhymes with it you know
years later you're like oh maybe we
could try it like this it worked once
before do you know yeah so it's like
increasing the toolbox of potential
methods all based on ones that have
worked in the past for one reason or
another and some of them are pretty
esoteric
so some are esoteric not all of them are
esoteric so I was no I was texting with
someone who read your book and what he
said was one of your
well I shouldn't say you are one of his
favorite Parts in the book was your take
on collaborations advice for people
working together whether as business
partners or artists when they disagree
strongly on something so would you mind
introducing maybe your philosophy or
tactical toolkit for helping to navigate
that because in your career I mean
you've dealt with many strong
personalities it's not set at a
pejorative way many big many unique
personalities how do you think about
interpersonal conflict resolution
in most collaborative projects most of
the Bands I've worked with the way that
I've noticed it working
is that there'll be many ideas
and they'll be like a battle of wills to
see which idea wins it's not necessarily
based in which ideas best it's more of a
ego conflict battle yep and then someone
who's either willing to fight more
or uh is more insensitive is able to
pushed their way through and that
becomes the direction
and from my experience
those are not how the best decisions are
made that's how a decision can get made
but not the best decision and really
what we want always is out of all the
possible decisions we want the best one
to end up in the peace
so we start with an agreement that
we try not to even know whose ideas are
which
to take the personal out of it and to
have it be
let's say there's a band with three
different songwriters in it
and then they might send me demos and in
the past they would say okay these three
are bills that means for Sams and these
are Sally's and then when I'm listening
to them I'm listening okay I have three
of Sam's four of Sally's
but I'm not focused on what's the best
of everything there because I'm thinking
about the individuals so I always ask
for any information shared with me to
not be labeled and not explained at all
and then I'm only reacting based on the
actual material not based on what I
think same goes when we're hiring a mix
engineer for something I might have as
many as five different mix Engineers mix
the same song and then I listen to them
without knowing who did what because if
one of them is a superstar mixer who
everybody wants and one of them is our
assistant engineer who works in the
studio
we might think oh the guy you know the
Superstar guy probably did the best job
and it it clouds the decision making not
intentionally even unintentionally
knowing the information is not helpful
so we do as much blind testing as
possible and the same is true is when
we're working together we all know
because we talk about it that what's
best isn't the best idea wins and that
there's no personal benefit and if your
idea makes it it doesn't make it better
than if the other team members idea
makes it because whichever idea actually
is best we all win
so that the goal is to get to the best
it's not to get to ours and to Foster
that relationship in all of the projects
we do with other people if someone's
always politicking to get it their way
it's a different job it's like you don't
want to win because of the politics you
want to win because the idea Works
totally no I was just going to ask you
if that is an explicit conversation you
have up front with people you're working
with so that you're studying the
expectations getting the buy-in having
everyone on the same page with this is
about the best ideas winning because
then we all win it's not about the
strongest egos winning the day and
pushing things through is that an
explicit conversation that you have with
folks or encourage them to have it can
be if I'm aware that it's an issue many
of the Bands I work with I've worked
with for a long period of time and I
also work with a lot of solo artists so
it doesn't apply to either of those
because if we've been working together
for a long time
it's baked into the process right but
with a new artist it may be a sit down
you know the first time it appears that
someone's just fighting for their idea
and maybe not even really listening that
to other people's ideas I would probably
have a sit-down conversation about it
you were talking about
listening to say mixes I'm using the
right term with fresh ears and I
remember in our first conversation we
talked briefly about
I think the term was the phrasing was
leaving music in the studio so that you
can come back to it with fresh ears if
you've heard something a hundred times
actually I'll give you a personal
situation and then maybe I can turn this
into a free therapy session so I have
been doing a bunch of fiction writing
for the last six months for the first
time and I'm having so much fun with it
it may in some ways tie into one of your
other true true passions people may not
realize this it's not [ __ ]
professional wrestling I don't know if
that's still the case but oh man they
may actually tie into this in a way that
I can explain another time but I've
really been enjoying the fiction what I
have found myself running into is I will
have a short short story a few pages
long and I will revise it 47 times I'll
revise it 56 times and when I look at
the amount of time I've spent on it a
few things
become apparent number one is that I'm
not convinced revision 56 is any better
necessarily than revision 49.
so maybe I could have spent less time on
that and done more original Drafting and
then the second is when I look at
something that many times
it all begins to get blurry and it
becomes so familiar that I it's very
challenging to look at it with fresh
eyes
and I imagine that happens to
folks you work with maybe it happened to
you in this creative process what advice
would you give say me or how would you
talk through that with me if I'm
experiencing those things first thing I
would suggest is always referring back
to the thing that you're revising I
would never assume because you put more
time into something it's getting better
yeah most people equate work time with
progress and that's not the case we're
scientists experimenting and it's all an
experiment
and sometimes we get the experiment
right right at the beginning and we
don't know it
and we won't know it until we may do a
hundred other iterations that are not
better
so what I'll say is there's no way to
save the time that you're hoping to save
there are no shortcuts
you got to do the 100 experiments no
matter what even if you get it right the
first the only way to know yeah and in
addition to that I would add on top of
it having patience and being able to
step away long enough that you can
compare idea 56 your latest with idea
one iteration one at the beginning and
see is it in fact better because
sometimes I mean there's a whole history
of albums that have come out where
people always say oh the album didn't
really work but the demos were great you
know it was so much better the
songwriting was great but we didn't
really execute it right so the Craft
part of iteration after iteration
could just as well be making it worse as
better it also can be making it better
it's like there's no rule to it so
that's why it's dangerous and then in
terms of
staying present
and leaving the work and working on
something else is a really good thing to
do because then when you come back
you've really exhausted another part of
your brain you know work on something
hard not bad and then when you come back
to read it you have a better chance of
being closer to uh a neutral view so
let's take an album as a parallel if you
have a you're working on an album
and there are X number of tracks just
for the sake of Simplicity let's say
there are 10 tracks and with this
fiction I was working on 10 different
stories related to Greater houses and
Clans and all this stuff in this
fictional world so I had the ability to
leave one and go to another if you're
working with a band and they have this
hypothetical album
what are your guiding principles for how
much to revise a given track
before moving on to something else or if
someone's feeling stuck how much you
push before moving to something else how
do you think about getting that album
done in terms of origination iteration
skipping around
if an idea is new and it's flowing I
would get as much of at least the first
draft of it all the way through a first
draft of that idea
I would probably not do any revision
past the first draft and then I would
move on to piece two I would want to get
to the 10 that you're doing from in my
case if I wanted to release 10 I would
be working on 30 to get to 10 to release
right so everything's the best of in my
mind it's like we have the best of these
three projects
I'd make that one project it's certainly
going to be better than the first 10.
for sure
so the first thing is I would overwrite
second thing is I would get the ideas
down as quickly as possible
through the idea finish the thought
then move on to the next one and get
them all to the point where you have a
great first draft of everything with the
ideas before ever going back and doing
another reason for that is
something may happen in episode eight
that informs a choice you're going to
make in episode one and two yeah that
happens and it's it's natural to happen
it's natural to happen when you look at
it in a holistic way when you see the
whole thing
you realize what's important where
there's opportunities for connections
that when you're working on the
individual pieces you'll never see yeah
totally and just on the micro level I
was working with this illustrator on
designs of these insignias for these
various Clans and by the time we got
through maybe two rounds of revisions
with two different insignias I realized
we have to see all of these side by side
absolutely to have some type of somatic
interconnectedness I can't keep refining
any given one I really have to see all
the rough drafts or I should say
intermediate drafts side by side or
we're just we're going to end up with a
product that is a frankincense
absolutely because when you see them all
together you may realize instead of
going forward with them you might want
to go backwards with them yeah maybe
they need to be
more abstract less specific less clear
you don't know it's impossible to know
until you see the group and then you
understand what's important and also
you'll know oh these all look really
good together and this one number six
this one's just not working you only
know that in the context of seeing them
all okay so I have a question for you
about genre and that might not be the
right word but you'll see where I'm
going with it
on one hand you have been involved with
some albums like rain and blood Slayer
right which has an undeniable
style to it it is just
unmistakable and I remember getting that
album horrified my parents but I got
that on cassette back in the stone ages
and it is one of a kind
on the other hand
I've read about examples let's just say
Red Hot Chili Peppers Circa 1991 where
you're encouraging them to reinvent
their sound
by incorporating different aspects and
maybe they thought at least in this New
York Times piece that the Chili Peppers
defined themselves as roughly let's just
say rap infused with funk and you
imagined expanding that when do you go
One Direction versus the other if that's
even a sensible question yeah yeah it's
a completely uh case-by-case thing and I
don't know how to judge it it has to do
with the whole Arc of an artist's work
if you look at the Beatles beetles are
always a great example because they're
really As Good As It Gets yeah and the
Beatles made 13 albums over seven years
and they're pretty radically different
over that seven years they're not
recognizable as the band before you
might even see them go through several
they probably went through
at least three maybe four different
phases within seven years if you think
about a big artists today
over seven years you might get two
albums that would probably be pretty
similar so it's really a radical thing
then on the other hand two of the
greatest groups of all time AC DC and
the Ramones
they pretty much do AC DC in the Ramones
every time and it doesn't change and you
don't want them to change and there's
not a right or wrong and it's not like
the Ramones is better than the Beatles
or the Beatles are better than the
Ramones they're just two different
trajectories totally and it's helpful to
figure out what your trajectory is
and it comes through the process I'll
give you an example of a band that I
worked with Linkin Park is a band that
was there was a movement called I don't
even know what you call it like the rap
rock movement the first of the rap rock
groups would have been Rage Against the
Machine let's say and then a bunch of
groups came in Rage Against the Machines
wake and it was a big movement that got
really big and then the last of those
groups was Linkin Park and one of the
most successful and they came to me
after they had made
I think three
of the biggest rap rock albums ever made
and there was some question about what
do we do next and an important point in
this is that rap rock as a genre was
disappearing
so they had a choice
and maybe this is part of the key I
never thought about this before if
you're part of a movement and if you're
riding a wave of a movement
and if the movement goes away
look closely at whether you want to keep
riding that same wave or not so in the
whatever reason my feeling was for
Lincoln Park at that time
if they made another one like their last
one it would have been wildly successful
and maybe one more
but then it would have sounded like the
oldies station
yeah right you know like it would have
been Retro Music and at the time that
they were making what they were making
it was really cutting edge
and their aspirations were
bigger than being
another rap rock group yeah
so for them the idea to shift out of
being just a rap rock group and try
different things was a good thing in the
case of the chili peppers they had made
Funk records with rap vocals for I think
four albums up until the time that I
worked with them
and
it was going fine and they could have
done that forever
but in spending time with them and
seeing the musicianship and seeing what
they did their potential and seeing the
relationship with the audience that they
had it was clear that the audience
didn't love them just because of the
style of music they were playing the
audience loved them because they loved
them and they put all of themselves into
it
so there was an opportunity to put all
of themselves into more in the case of
the chili peppers and just widened that
envelope same with Lincoln Park just
like widen the envelope
and
there have been other artists I've
worked with where I suggest doing the
exact opposite you know where I suggest
going back to what you used to do that
worked there's not a right or a wrong
way it really is looking at all of the
elements and so much of it has to do
with how they see themselves
and what their long-term goals are for
sure you know I got to make an album
with AC DC they never wanted to sound
any different than AC DC for them that's
all that music sounded like that's what
music sounds like AC DC we do the good
version of what music is
there was no chance that they were going
to start doing battle if you have piano
balance it's not going to happen
that's a great example and it also
strikes me that I have to imagine I
don't know if this has been your
experience but
for long-term endurance and just
creative output sustained over longer
periods
it would seem to be most
people this is certainly true for a lot
of writers need to have some congruency
between like what they're feeling and
what they want to be and what they're
actually doing right even if you're
surfing for a wave that is a huge
movement you happen to do pretty well if
that isn't resonating intrinsically with
what you deeply want to do
is going to be very hard to sustain that
for a period of time I would have to
imagine I think it's impossible I think
it's impossible and I think if you are
trying to ride a wave and you're not
already connected with all of yourself
chances are that won't even be
successful yeah you know it'll just be
more the same it won't it won't matter
yeah so let me ask a question about the
book compositions and some of the
decisions so the Publishers who said to
you like Rick let's share what we think
is going to work great so if you're if
we're going to get a get somebody to
help you with a bio we're going to put
in all the stories about the rock stars
and this and that and then father Rick
said no thank you thank you but no thank
you and you've written this book my
question for you because I know there's
thinking behind it or feeling behind it
or both why not do both in the sense
that you could
sprinkle a little bit of this inside
a foundation of the other and probably
make it work why was it important for
you not to move strongly in the
direction of where you were feeling the
external pressure
two reasons first one is I want the book
to be a Timeless book yeah and if the
examples were about me and my life they
would be attached to me in my life they
may not mean something in 20 years or 30
years or 50 years and I want it to be a
forever like the doubt that I was
written 3000 years ago I wanted to be
able to live outside of time that's one
the other reason is
in terms of the nature of
wanting the reader inviting the reader
to participate in the book
if I tell you a possible solution to a
problem
and if I
paint a picture of the problem and the
solution and you see the way it works
when you're reading it you're
envisioning your self-solving that
problem it's written in that way to
allow you to see it happen for yourself
if I do that same exercise and it's a
story about Jay-Z You're not picturing
yourself solving that problem you're
thinking wow Jay-Z such a great artist
do you know what I'm saying it removes
you from it I never wanted
The Sensational nature or the celebrity
nature
of how you hear a story when you know
who's involved and it's someone you like
or don't like either way it's just like
the a b testing I was saying earlier of
not wanting to know any information I'm
giving the audience the chance to hear
the information without The Sensational
stuff that's a distraction
I didn't want it to have the distraction
I wanted it to actually be helpful
foreign
just a quick thanks to one of our
sponsors and we'll be right back to the
show this episode is brought to you by
wealthfront there is a lot happening in
the U.S and Global economies right now a
lot that's an understatement are we in a
recession is it a bear Market what's
going to happen with inflation so many
questions so few answers I can't tell
the future nobody can but I can tell you
about a great place to earn more on your
savings and that's wealthfront
wealthfront is an app that helps you
save and invest your money right now you
can earn 3.8 API that's the annual
percentage yield with the wealthfront
cash account that's more than 15 times
more interest than if you left your
money in a savings account at the
average Bank according to fdic.gov
getting a cash account is easy it takes
just a few minutes to sign up and then
you'll immediately start earning 3.8
percent interest on your savings and
when you open an account today you'll
get an extra 50 bonus with a deposit of
500 or more visit wealthfront.com Tim to
get started there are already nearly
half a million people using wealthfront
to save more earn more and build
long-term wealth so why wait earn 3.8
percent on your cash today plus it's up
to two million dollars in FDIC insurance
through partner Banks visit
wealthfront.com Tim to get started
that's wealthfront.com Tim this was a
paid endorsement by wealthfront
so coming back to the split testing
for a moment you had indicated at the
beginning of that story that I think
that is
or that section is within cooperation I
think the a b testing is in a whole
different section I don't know okay all
right but the cooperation and the
collaboration are different I think yes
collaboration you would expect to be
working with others but it's not the
collaboration section is about working
with yourself and the universe that
everything we make is a collaboration
because we're not doing anything
ourselves everything we do is based on
the information that we take in our
experiences in life what we learned in
school
a conversation we had yesterday all of
the things that make us who we are we
bring into all of our projects so we're
always in collaboration it's never our
idea
to build off that there's a quote that I
wrote down from page 41 which is
look for what you notice but no one else
sees and perhaps this is related right
to that collaboration between the Seer
and the scene the receiver in the center
maybe one and the same but I'd want to
take us to esoteric what does that mean
to you look for what you notice but no
one else sees and maybe if there are any
examples that come to mind or how could
someone begin to hone them if you speak
to a scientist or a mathematician about
some problem that was very difficult to
solve
that eventually when they get to the
solution
it's not exotic it more often than not
it was right there the whole time it was
so obvious we miss what's right in front
of us we have great opportunities to
participate in incredible beauty and
inspiration every day everywhere we go
and opening ourselves to be in that
state that allows for us to see the
thing that everyone else is walking by
and happened to me uh yesterday I was
walking by a tree with my son and I
noticed that there was a big tree and a
very narrow tree and the narrow tree had
these like flat I don't even know how to
describe them they looked like almost
the shape of butterflies big flat
protrusions
sticking way off this little tree
they would darken color and it wasn't
clear to me are those part of the tree
is that something that's growing on the
tree have no idea
but I've walked by that same tree every
day for six weeks and I never noticed
that before and here I noticed it and
now I have a question it's like in
addition to it being beautiful and in
addition to having the conversation with
my sons like you think that those are
growing on the tree or is that part of
the tree it's like I think maybe the
growing on it fascinating but I walked
by it many times without noticing it I
noticed it and if I was going to draw
something that day I would probably try
to analyze and draw those because it was
so it's so cool looking and I never saw
anything like it before hiding in plain
sight hiding in plain sight so I'm gonna
pull up
something else which is at the very
beginning of the book
which is a quote and I'm not sure how to
pronounce this name so I'm gonna give it
a go either Robert Henry or Robert Henry
I'm guessing
h-e-n-r-i and the quote is he's American
I think it might be Henry but I'm not
I'm also not sure okay I think so all
right so I'll go with Robert Henry
h-e-n-r-i and the object isn't to make
art it's to be in that wonderful state
which makes art inevitable I would love
for you to
flesh this out a little bit and maybe
the way to do it would be too pure
stories of your own I mean you may have
just given one but how you cultivate the
precursors
the elemental pieces of this state that
makes art inevitable and that could be
through yourself could be through people
you've worked with but what does that
look like when it's done well
the whole book is is the answer to that
question and the reason the subtitle of
the book is a way of being
is
being a great artist we think of it as
the person who makes the thing we think
about it as the making
what makes an artist great
happens not in the making it happens in
the way of being in the world the way of
experiencing the world the way of
noticing the thing that someone else
doesn't notice the way of seeing what's
beautiful when everyone else sees the
mundane and being able to
represent that back in a way that other
people get a glimpse of what we saw that
they didn't notice we get to walk around
in awe all day and have our breath taken
away and then we get to portray that in
something where someone else hopefully
could have that same sense of awe from
something we made
so this for me begs the question of
is there a way to distinguish between
good distraction and bad distractions so
bad distraction might be
commercial considerations that lead you
to chase this
Hungry Ghost in a way that completely
impedes your creative process right so
maybe that's a bad distraction which we
talked a bit about in our last
conversation on the podcast
somebody from the outside looking at you
staring at this growth on the tree might
say Rick's got a lot of important stuff
to do he's getting really distracted
right so is there a good light in which
to paint distraction or a way to think
about that to what extent you immerse
yourself in the the sublime details that
the rest of the world misses
and Alternate that with periods of
taking it into the workshop so to speak
the work is the work of a Craftsman the
building of things that's the
craftsperson's job
and there's a difference between a
craftsperson and an artist
one's not better than the other they're
both fine
it's just a different way of looking at
it
the craftsperson is making the thing and
making them all the same and making them
all match or making the one that that
somebody ordered and it's a very
specific
how do you want it okay I can make it
that way the way you want it that's the
craftsperson the artist is
making the thing that you didn't know
you want the thing that you didn't know
that you couldn't live without the thing
that you didn't know was possible and to
do that it's different than learning how
to make things yeah it's a different
process it has more to do with our
connection to the world than anything
else and when I say connection to the
world that could mean
watching old movies it could mean
reading great literature it could mean
going to museums it could mean being in
nature it could mean doing something
physical like I would consider exercise
a form of distraction from our work if
you're concerned about something if you
go exercise really hard chances are you
won't be thinking about what you're
concerned about if you're working hard
enough same with the ice tub that we got
to do together when you're in the ice
Nothing Else Matters everything's fine
they're also specific distraction that's
really helpful for the artist where
because we tend to be overthinking
creatures
it goes back to your earlier question
about do I move on to number two before
you know before I finish number one we
tend to over things like oh I could work
on number one forever I'm never gonna
get to number 10. there are certain
distractions we can do that make it
easier there was an artist I was working
with I can say Neil Diamond the singer
and Neil Diamond sings his incredible
voice and he sings like almost like an
opera singer like very big projecting
voice and
people tend to think of him as a overly
dramatic singer some people might even
make fun of him for being an overly
dramatic singer and he's a rudimentary
guitar player at best he writes his
songs on guitar but he's not a studio
musician when we were working together I
insisted that when he sang he also
played guitar and he's like I never play
on my records why would I play guitar in
my records I could have a great guitar
player say no no I just want you to play
and what happened was
through his playing he was
distracted enough
by having to hold down the chord changes
he was able to sing just like himself
there was no potential
to make it a performance right and the
goal was to not make it a performance
the goal was to get closer to reality
where it's real where you believe what
he's saying you know we didn't want a
Shakespearean performance we wanted
his heart opening and we were best able
to get that when he was playing guitar
so this example ties in perfectly to
where I was going and where I'd love to
go which is breaking out of sameness
when we have these habits we may have
these defaults and there are different
reasons for
sticking with sameness right or
different explanations one is we found
this let's just say genre that works
it's doing well let's kind of milk this
as long as we can there's a at least one
other form of sameness which is I have
these habits and I don't know how to
break these habits right like I would
love to try something new but I'm not
sure how to do it because I've been
doing more or less something that rhymes
with this for so long what are some
other ways you've seen people
successfully innovate experiment and
maybe get off of those well-worn facts
an example for you writing fiction is a
great example because you've written
nonfiction up till now although I still
think you don't have that issue because
you wrote your first book which was a
business book it was wildly successful
and then I remember your second book was
a fitness book and Publishers were like
you're the business guy what are you
writing a fitness book for yeah exactly
yes so you don't have this problem or at
least you didn't have the problem then
when we talked about it then I don't
have a problem with it yeah I think if
you look back at your work and you
notice a pattern that runs through it
there are two choices one you can double
down on that pattern and through
recognizing it go deeper into it and
that could be interesting or you could
recognize the pattern and say okay what
would it be like if I went in a
different direction if your work tends
to be dark you've done dark dark dark
dark dark what would the light version
be like interesting who knows yeah
what's the other end of the Seesaw and
even if you do that experiment and don't
like the results when you come back to
working in the dark you're going to have
a different relationship to it you're
going to be able to do something new
even if you're going to go back to the
same thread that you've been following
breaking out of it
even as a failed experiment can help you
get firmly back
on the thread in a way maybe more secure
than you ever understood it before yeah
that makes a lot of sense to me if
you're always in the cave and you want
to describe the cave and the Darkness in
the cave and you're going to have maybe
a broader
spectrum of vocabulary and certainly
personal experience to use if you spend
some time walking around in the sunlight
and then you go back in the cave yeah
you'll notice completely different
things yeah I like that and question
this is also a self-interested question
but I'm writing this fiction and I'm not
using
public consensus or requests to drive
any creative decisions and I feel that's
important for me to say up front because
I know that's a risk when you start
letting Mass opinion or crowd input
Drive the entire creative process I
think you can end up being a camel as a
horse designed by committee type of
situation so I'm not doing that what I
have noticed is
unlike with my non-fiction on one hand I
I really want to get some positive
reinforcement because I'm new and it's a
little wobbly I'm proud of certain
aspects of it
but looking for that can be a risky
business because if you go online if you
go on Twitter there are for every one
person who may give constructive
feedback there are 10 others who are
just going to try to Lop your head off
with really destructive feedback what
type of advice do you give to your
artists or would you give to me with
respect to fully ignoring or cherry
picking or soliciting feedback it
doesn't have to be from the internet but
just given that context what would you
say
I would say to try to find a way to get
feedback from people who genuinely care
about you and your work not a general
reader and in your case specifically
because you write a blog how do you
email that blog to people you have a big
mailing list so I would start if I were
you not posting things on Twitter but
just sending them to your mailing list
and getting response that way because if
someone signed up to your mailing list
they're not signing up to hate you yeah
yeah right they're invested they don't
want to be erasing your emails every
time you send them
they're welcoming them so I would start
with with a welcoming audience if you're
going to be getting any any feedback and
I would have a because they are a
welcoming audience have a big enough
scale where it's not just I love this I
love this I love this you know to get
some actual helpful information let me
ask you this is a bit of a left turn but
I'm so curious to get your take
and my apologies if a lot of people have
asked you this but I've never heard you
speak to this publicly I first and
foremost would consider myself a
non-fiction writer and in the last few
months I've been tracking
artificial intelligence enhanced or
dependent
copy production blog posts tell me a
story about a guy trying to get a piece
of toast out of his toaster with a
butter knife in the style of the King
James Bible some of what you're seeing
with Chad GPT and so on is astonishing
and most recently and this is speaking
as someone who comes from an art family
and as someone who wants to be a comic
book penciler for a long time I've been
watching with some degree of awe these
tools like mid-journey and stable
diffusion and so on some of which are
now being applied to music and they're
interpolating from say
keyboard Strokes to improv Jazz with a
touch of funk and it's been astonishing
to watch how much this has gone vertical
in the last few months at least in terms
of mass adoption and experimentation 15
years ago at least as covered in New
York Times 2007 you said that the way or
one of the ways to counter not
counteract but offset file sharing was
to offer people a subscription model
much like cable right it's a lo and
behold that has happened and people have
these subscriptions and they have music
at their fingertips in their living room
in their car Etc what are your thoughts
on artificial intelligence and how it
fits or doesn't fit into creativity I
think of it as an end it doesn't strike
me as interesting as a means it could be
helpful for example what's interesting
about the things we make again isn't the
making the computer is doing the making
it's not doing the noticing
so I might ask in the same way that we
spend time like hip-hop producers do
crate digging where we'll listen to
hundreds of old albums track by track
looking for a moment that's interesting
we're not looking for the song We're Not
Looking for the piece of work we're
looking for a moment where things go
right
or a moment that just strikes us and
then that's an element that we can
integrate into our work so I might
consider having a music making program
constantly making music and then listen
for at any point in time over the hours
and hours all day long probably have it
playing in the background all all day
and then any time there was a moment
that made me look you know that would
catch my ear I would sample that moment
and try to build something with human
taste
with that as a seed to build from or is
an element used I think what's
interesting the human curation
aspect of art is it's what makes it art
so I don't even know what it is if a
computer makes it I don't know I've also
not seen any personally thus far I've
not seen any computer generated images
based on instructions that have moved me
in any way I haven't felt them I haven't
felt them I may see them I might laugh
at them or I might think oh that's a
funny cartoon but never does it make me
want to learn more or go deeper or uh
feel something bigger
there's also the question that if humans
are going to want to or be willing to
feel something if they know that it's
been generated
by a computer right by AI well they
won't always know I can't imagine they
would always know right yeah it's going
to get harder and harder to distinguish
when you hear something that catches
your ear or when you think back to some
of these songs whether it's from the
Beatles or Neil Young or otherwise that
move you deeply what does that feel like
can you describe that quickening because
it strikes me that you used your felt
sense and response to things
as a guiding Rod of sorts can you
describe what that feeling is like
one of the elements is surprise it holds
my attention
and it surprises me if it comes on and I
like it and it only does
what it did to make me initially like it
I might lose interest
but if it does something that's
interesting and catches my ear
and makes me lean forward to understand
what's happening why am I feeling this
what what's going on here and it holds
that Curiosity and anytime it makes me
want to turn it off I know that's not
for me if I want to turn it off it's not
for me and if I want to listen to it
forever I really like it
if your son comes to you
who knows when could be tomorrow but
let's just say it's it's a handful of
Year shannounces Dad I really want to be
a music producer and somehow made The
Plea could you walk me through this
Padawan training to become the best
music producer possible how would you
begin to respond to that or how might
you think about that would there be
certain things you'd want to impart it's
probably absorbing a lot just through
exposure to you and osmosis and so on
I'm sure I think it would really just
start with talking about learning about
seeing lots of art listening to lots of
music seeing as much as we could and
trying to understand why do we like the
things we like and not like things we
don't what are the qualities in there
some of them are not describable some of
them are beyond words but to get in tune
with these feelings that language
doesn't do justice to
and to feel that feeling when your
breath gets taken away I feel like for
young children they probably have it
more often than we do as jaded adults
because the world is still new to them
so
the first time you see anything Grand
I've never been to the Grand Canyon I
imagine the first time I go even though
I haven't been there and I've seen
pictures I will probably have some
feeling of wow can't believe it's that
big that's my guess and whatever my
imagination is of it won't be as
dramatic and Grand as what I expect to
see when I get there we'll see when that
happens there was a sunset yesterday I
was doing a Tai Chi exercise on the
beach and there was an incredible Sunset
and the
the way the light was reflecting on the
water and the colors in the sky and the
changes and in One Direction it was
orange and like uh bright light and in
the other direction it was dark and
almost stormy even though it wasn't
stormy at all but the sense of it was
like if you were on a boat it would feel
like we're going into the storm and
feeling all of that drama was so
exciting and I came back after and it's
like I wasn't even here anymore you know
like I was taken into another world
and the more often you can do that and
experience that feeling of being just
taken out of your body by art or by
nature or by stimulus whatever it is
and then having that as your meter
setting for what we're looking for
what's the thing that we can make that
starts touching those buttons
the button of I never want to leave here
amazing this is the same world that I
you know when I got out of my car and
walked here this is the same place it's
unbelievable
that dissolution of time that's stepping
into the slipstream where things seem to
disappear but at the same time
everything is present all at once which
might have been the experience and
amplify I would say and amplify more
it's just like
there's so much to take in and it's just
overwhelming and all beautiful
who have you met and you don't have to
name names but I'm curious if you could
describe
anyone I mean you could also name names
but people who have been able to access
that type of state with regularity
without becoming
dissociated from this consensus reality
right because there are people you meet
who are almost always in and I don't
want to say altered but sort of a
parallel State like that but they're not
able to operate in the world very well
what have you seen in terms of people
who are able to regularly access that
and also are able to operate well in
this reality
I would say the ones who really can do
it best
manage in this reality but I wouldn't
say that they I feel like they live in
the other place so Neil Young would be
an example who lives in the place where
the music is and he's great on a
day-to-day basis and fine
but when the music starts and when he's
playing his instrument and when he's
inside of that
every time not sometimes it's like he's
goes to another place
and it's magic
wherever he's going the music there is
real
how much of that do you think is is like
an inborn ability to have a very high
vertical jump or to have the hamstring
and
tendon attachments of like an Usain Bolt
for sprinting versus cultivated now we
can all become faster Runners we can all
learn to jump a bit higher have you met
anyone who has really trained that
ability or are most of them
just by virtue of being these
brilliant artists who enter your orbit
coming into it with just a very high set
point for entering the spaces
you can definitely get there in
different ways that said
not everyone can be da Vinci yeah we can
all be the best we can be that's all we
can ever be as the best we can be being
the best we can be doesn't necessarily
mean that when we do our best we are the
best in the world or even world class
we're not all world class at everything
all the time doesn't matter though the
people who were great who find their way
in
some people might say Bob Dylan doesn't
have a great voice
but he's a singer-songwriter who's maybe
the most loved in the world
so he wasn't born with this virtuoso he
doesn't sing like Neil Diamond for
example
and some people I'm sure are very happy
that he doesn't
do you know what I'm saying it's like
we're not all great at everything so if
we get great at the thing that we're
great at
and if we get get great at the thing
that we're great at that not so many
other people are great at in the way
that we are and that's usually the case
with music like the reason there are so
many musical artists and the reason you
know I have thousands of albums of
artists and thousands of artists that I
follow that I love
isn't because they're all the best one
it's they all do something really good
particular to them
and I want the one who really does the
good thing particular to them and Johnny
Ramon can't play guitar like Eric
Clapton
but he can play guitar like Johnny
Ramone
and I'm good with that I'm good with
both do you know what I'm saying find
your thing where is your connection
what's interesting and hopefully it
aligns with what you're interested in
doing because that's probably the only
way that it becomes uh a sustainable
thing
how do you manage your inspirational
intake on that many artists are you
listening all the time do you have set
time where you'll sit down and listen
for a handful of hours what does that
look like I'm a mass consumer of
information and and art all the time I'm
always reading listening taking in stuff
but I'm not always taking in it's what I
enjoy I'm not doing it like homework I'm
doing it because that's the reason I am
who I am is because that's how I've
always done it that's my default
mechanism is
I want to hear as much as I can I want
to understand more I don't want to hear
stuff I don't want to hear but I want to
hear everything that I might want to
hear and I want to exhaust the list to
make sure I'm not missing anything as
best I can I try to dive as deep as I
can lately it's hard just because
there's so much of all kinds of content
so certain things Fall by the wayside
for example movies I haven't seen very
many new movies in a long time on
occasion but not so many why is that I
don't know it's just one of the things
that fell out I'm not sure why
there are a couple of movies I'm excited
to see now and I may or may not get to
see them well this will be topical I'm
curious why are you interested to see
them what are the Moonies what is one or
two
two that I want to see there's a new
David Bowie documentary that I'm curious
about a friend of mine directed it and
it sounds really beautiful and I tend to
like documentaries the other is a movie
called tar which several people told me
they really loved and usually when
several people tell me something's good
I feel like the universe wants me to see
this like like it's the way I can
interpret it is if more than one person
is recommending something I don't talk
to that many people if multiple people
are telling me you got to see this
chances are
something in the universe wants this to
happen so I want to follow through
I want to do my part The Muse is winking
at you from across the room being like
hey pal come on I'm giving you the cue
all right tar
what is your coaching or your
wisdom to artists who are concerned
about endurance and the endurance could
come in the form of
touring before they do their next studio
recording you could come in in many
different
species I'm sure in my case there's
definitely part of me that wonders
how will I continue to execute as I hope
for at least a while
in writing one short fiction piece per
week that's what I would like to do
because I feel like that Cadence is
something I can probably manage there
will be weeks where it'll be tougher
than others because of the revision
but there's certainly a small part of me
that's concerned that that will begin to
stack up right I'll be like oh [ __ ] I
thought I was going to finish one a week
but now I have two that are in revision
one that's in draft and it's Thursday
what am I going to do so that's my
personal context but we could expand it
to others you've worked with who might
have some concerns how many hours will
it take to do the one this is a very
fair question and I will say that in
some I don't know what the magic is I
sit down I've had the right coffee with
the right omelet I don't know what the
pixie dust is and I zoom through and
then two hours I'm done and it just
comes out and I look at it a week later
I'm like I'm not going to change
anything maybe I'll tweak a few words
but it's done and then there are others
that we'll take
10 to 15 hours which is in addition to
all of my other
projects right the podcast and
everything else so there's a lot there's
a lot of other things going on which I
enjoy doing yeah always yeah but let's
let's say 15 hours
Okay so
you can decide how important it is to
you and if it's really important to you
you can say I'm going to make a
commitment
where
I'm gonna do this even if it takes 15
hours you could decide I'm gonna do it
every Monday you know I I'm not going to
go to sleep until I have the one for the
week you could do it every day you can
do it as often as you want if you're
willing to make that commitment
and in terms of running dry
clearly they won't some will be better
than others
the whole process will make you better
you know this whole Adventure at the end
of uh 50 weeks you'll be better at it
than you were the first week clearly
and it'll be a roller coaster ride and
there'll be highs and lows on the way
and by the way you put this on yourself
you're like I am deciding I want one a
week it's not like there's a gun to your
head and then you know you're not going
to make it if you don't do it
so it depends on how strong your
commitment is but 15 hours out of all of
the hours of a week regardless of
anything else you have to do if you
commit to it that's absolutely doable
because there's a lot more than 15 hours
in a week you could commit to doing it
your every waking hour if you decide to
commit it's purely a commitment now you
can't control what comes out of it and
maybe at some point you might realize
this is not the right Cadence for me who
knows yeah or you may decide to do two a
week at some point like this is it's
rolling
be open but starting with a commitment
that you think is a doable Commitment if
you think this is a doable amount commit
to it and just do it I mean you've
exercised before you have great
discipline it's purely a matter of
discipline you could do anything you
commit to
gotta get on the calendar just that it's
blocked out it's a case of me also
taking something that is new and maybe
mistaking it for entirely new does that
make sense because I don't think about
fiction in the same way that I think
about exercise so I'll do my exercise
and that's on autopilot and I've done it
and I understand it whereas the fiction
I I might
over
exaggerate in terms of its exotic nature
and the newness and the alien life form
that is this new Narrative Approach I'm
trying to take but I suppose on so many
levels it's just like getting the
groceries or doing something else it's
absolutely the same as everything else
you do and maybe there's a way that you
can think about it as an opportunity to
have fun because in those times you're
going to get to find out what these
characters are doing and I'm I hope
you're curious like I hope you want to
know what's going to happen next and
that's a good feeling it's like if you
watch any type of a series
when you get left at the end of the
first week of a series second week or
third week and there's another one and
you can't wait till the next one comes
maybe you can train yourself
to know that I get to see what happens
in the story next week
so I am there this is the good news the
good news is that part of why I wanted
to play with fiction is that I get to
set the initial conditions and this
space and this world I get to throw in
all these weird loose ends that I don't
know how I'm gonna tie up and then I get
to tap dance and
sort of rap Morse code on the wall and
see what comes back
and that's fun it's because it's totally
different from non-fiction it's totally
different and so this is the first time
that I have really on a weekly basis
been
dancing with the muses in a sense
in such a direct way yeah it's been
fantastic how did you think about pacing
with the book because there's
on one hand the not knowing of what's
going to emerge but you could wait and
wait and wait and the book would never
manifest so how did you think for
yourself about commitment and pacing or
time scale anything how did you think
about the book
I thought of it as I'm willing to do
whatever it takes for as long as it
takes for it to be as good as it could
be
until I don't know what to do anymore
and that happened some time ago really
but at that time it wasn't in the
present form so it didn't start with
okay they're going to be 78 areas of
thought and these are what the 78 areas
of thought are and then I write those
that is not what happened it was a
general
Conversation Over years about the
philosophy of the creative process and
then looking at you know one point
thousand pages of
talk that's it's all about creativity
but it's not in any order and it's not
in any
form and then it was years to figure out
how to turn that into what this is right
to go from the transcripts and the
exploration and conversation
to
the book and the format that we we
currently see it
yeah it wasn't planned this way at all I
went in with a blank slate I had an
intention
I had an intention of what I wanted it
to accomplish
but that's all
how I wanted it to feel I would say
that's another part of it when you read
it it feels a certain way there were
earlier versions where the information
was
another version of the same information
but it didn't
make you want to make something it
didn't
hit you in an emotional way I can only
read the book you know a couple of
sections at a time and I for me it's a
very slow read yeah not because it's
complicated but because there's just a
lot to think about it's talking about
internal experiences and it's
it's just a lot to consider well I think
you and I were texting about the way one
might approach reading this book and I
think you were saying that one approach
could be just one short chapter a few
pages before bed and that's it right
because I'm reading it and if you
actually sit to
simulate this and to soak in it if you
read 100 Pages it's you're going to be
getting waterboarded by
absolutely so much potential energy in
so many different directions it'll be
very hard to digest over a really short
period of time when this book comes out
and the book will be out shortly and
let's just say six months have passed
are there any sections you really hope
people don't overlook and of course you
want people to read the whole thing but
there are people who will pick it up and
probably try to go to whatever the
sexiest shiny objects are that draw
their attention are there any particular
sections that you would
hope people do not miss
nope I hope anyone who's interested
opens it randomly reads something
wherever their eyes go I hope they find
something that's helpful and if so maybe
they want to do that again that's all
I would expect no less from Rick Rubin
well Rick is there anything else that
you would like to talk about or
mention I mean we need to set a date so
then I can actually see you in person
and give you a hug it'd be nice to see
you again I would love that and
we've covered a lot already is there
anything else that you would like to
share in terms of closing comments
questions suggestions public complaints
anything at all
anything anything you can think of I can
say this Rick that your book the
creative act a way of being has found me
at the perfect time so I'm glad it took
so long in a sense because it's catching
me right at the time that I'm flying by
on this terrain called experimental
fiction and I can sort of grab the book
as you hand it off to me and I think it
will be a tremendous help because you
have been not just the Creator
of so much you've been The Shepherd of
so much and you've also had an
opportunity to work in so many different
capacities with so many different
artists that your pattern recognition
and your way of interpreting and
conveying that I think is
unique it really is
one of a kind and I can say that also
just having spent time with you I
appreciate the way that you think and
furthermore because
humans are built for thinking we have
this thing the blessing and the curse of
this huge prefrontal cortex but I am
particularly impressed with how you are
able to use your other means of knowing
and senses to inform what you do with
this incredible brand of yours and
reading the book
I am very optimistic that you're going
to help people to calibrate and open
themselves up to Greater possibilities
so I just wanted to congratulate you I
know how long this has been in the
making so congratulations Rick
thank you so much I really appreciate it
I'm so thank you so much for giving it
some time oh yeah what I need because I
only have a PDF I need a physical copy
and I'll take a Gala it doesn't need to
be finished just something I can carry
around because I'm still very
old-fashioned I like to scribble it
looks like this is the Prototype Edition
I can see it oh that's that's nice the
main version is the opposite the
background is gray and the type is black
and equally beautiful love it but this
was just first as a like a sample for us
to understand how yeah yeah I love it
very iconic very simple very sort of Zen
painting brush stroke and dig it man
well Rick thank you so much for the time
people can find you on Twitter at Rick
Rubin and we'll link to everything
including the book and anything that
came up in conversation at tim.blog
podcast for people listening but to be
continued I'm excited now that we're not
in lockdown and
I have to get a get a date on the
calendar to say hello so please give my
best to the family will do and I can't
wait till we see each other in person
too yeah great to see you Rick same man
hey guys this is Tim again just one more
thing before you take off and that is
five bullet Friday would you enjoy
getting a short email from me every
Friday that provides a little fun before
the weekend between one and a half and
two million people subscribe to my free
newsletter my super short newsletter
called five bullet Friday easy to sign
up easy to cancel it is basically a half
page that I send out every Friday to
share the coolest things I've found or
discovered or have started exploring
over that week it's kind of like my
diary of cool things it often includes
articles I'm reading books I'm reading
albums perhaps gadgets gizmos all sorts
of tech tricks and so on that get sent
to me by my friends including a lot of
podcasts guests and these strange
esoteric things end up in my field and
then I test them and then I share them
with you so if that sounds fun again
it's very short a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend something to think about if
you'd like to try it out just go to
tim.blog Friday type that into your
browser Tim dot blog slash Friday drop
in your email and you'll get the very
next one thanks for listening
this episode is brought to you by you
need a budget what is you need a budget
you need a budget is a cult favorite
budgeting app for a reason the app and
its simple four rule method will change
the way you think about your money and
help you gain total control so you can
plan for the things you need and get the
things you want without guilt or stress
to give you an idea on the cult favorite
side to date they know of at least seven
customers who have customized their
license plates to Mark the occasion of
purchasing a new car in cash and these
fans do this by including YNAB you need
a budget on their license plates so
people love this app you need a budget
has helped millions of people transform
their finances save their marriages and
live life on their own terms I even
asked Pete Adney who's been on the
podcast best known as Mr Money Mustache
super popular episode what he thought
and he's a big fan of the founder and
what they're doing you need a budgets
simple four rule method will actually
teach you how to manage your money you
will learn a new way of thinking new
habits and new behaviors that will help
you get out of debt break the paycheck
to paycheck cycle and build wealth
faster the you need a budget team is
committed to your success they offer
free live classes every day of the week
video courses boot camps challenges and
active fan groups in every corner of the
internet if you want to learn they can
teach you on average new budgeters save
more than 600 by month two at six
thousand dollars in their first year so
try the app free for 34 days no credit
card required at you need a budget.com
Tim spelled as you would expect in
proper English try you need a budget
free for 34 days no credit card required
at you need a budget.com Tim and just to
explain 34 days that's because most
people reconcile at the end of the month
or 38 periods of having a couple of days
of cushion helps folks out so 34 days
with no credit card required at you need
a budget.com slash tip
this episode is brought to you by
Peloton and their brand new Peloton row
Peloton row brings personalized form
features and guidance to rowing to help
you learn and master your stroke this
was always a weak point for me meaning
before I used volaton row and I got to
test a unit a few weeks ago here in
Austin which blew me away my form was
just a question mark and I also tended
to flame out after five or ten minutes
on a rower I just really didn't know
what I was doing and with the Peloton
row that all changed the instructors
first and foremost highly trained
Fitness Pros many different types who
motivate you through every rowing
workout I really enjoyed my training
sessions with Alex karwaski specifically
he's a current high-level International
competitor in rowing so you know his
technique has been refined Peloton
offers a huge variety of workouts like
high intensity interval training hit
rows endurance rows and more with the
feedback that I was able to get so you
effectively see a profile of yourself
and based on sensors at different points
in the machine you will see feedback I
was able to then do a much more
sustained workout to actually tax
different metabolic systems and I felt
spectacular afterwards form features
like form assist indicate how to improve
your stroke in class in real time and
you also get a detailed post-class
breakdown so you can hit the rail harder
but more technically next time in my
opinion you can turn off the pharmacist
after about three minutes or so you'll
probably get most of what you're going
to get in each of those sessions and
you'd want to become too overly
concerned with that so that it detracts
from your experience with all these
features you can personalize your target
metrics you become the expert at the
level and Pace that feels good for you
you get all the cardio and strength in
one shot while protecting your joints
and ligaments in a high intensity but
low impact method of exercise and this
blew my mind also my ankles sometimes
hurt when I've tried rowing in the past
and by getting the proper instruction I
felt no pain in my feet or my ankles
whatsoever and the Pelton row fits
seamlessly into your life so whether you
have a 10 minute segment of time a
little break between calls or if you
want to do something longer in a low
impact row on a recovery day all those
options are available and the Peloton
row also can be stored vertically so
when you're not using it it's out of
sight out of mind it's also effectively
near silent when you're using it there's
a class for every schedule you can work
out hard for the time that you have and
trust that you're getting the most out
of each workout right now it is the
perfect time to get rowing with Colleton
row I can promise that you've never rode
like this before the Forum feedback
perform assist I was really really
impressed Peloton row offers a variety
of classes for all levels Plus game
changing features that help you get
rowing or Advance the rowing you already
do so explore Peloton row at one Peloton
that's o-n-e one peloton.com row one
more time that's one peloton.com
bro
[Applause]